bonsoir et bienvenue ravi de vous
retrouver en direct pour savour garde
rentrer parlementaire avec un grand
témoin exceptionnel ce soir bonsoir
Laurent Berger bonsoir et merci d'être
là secrétaire général de la CFDT pour
encore quelques semaines puisque vous
passerez la main le 21 juin prochain en
plein retour en grâce des syndicats on
pouvait pas rêver mieux comme contexte
on va en parler on va dresser le bilan
de vos quelques dix ans et demi à la
tête de la CFDT tout à l'heure mais on
va commencer par débattre ce soir de
l'avenir de la contestation l'interdy
syndicale a décidé d'une 14e journée
d'action ce sera le 6 juin prochain pour
se faire entendre des députés ils
examineront deux jours plus tard une
proposition de loi visant à abroger la
réforme et d'ici là l'exécutif espère
tourner la page en renouant le dialogue
alors comment et puis sur quoi
précisément grand débat entre Laurent
Berger et trois députés dans un instant
sur ce plateau avant de retrouver aux
alentours de 20h15 les parties pris de
nos affranchis et puis d'en Bourbon
Express ce soir l'histoire
d'un retour celui d'un certain François
Fillon à l'Assemblée nationale voilà
pour le menu vous me suivez Laurent
Berger c'est parti
[Musique]
on les disait au bord de la rupture et
bien il reste uni au moins jusqu'au 8
juin les syndicats se sont donc mis
d'accord pour une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation et vous y étiez Laurent
Berger en visioconférence
l'interpindicale va donc appeler à
mobiliser le pays contre la réforme le 6
juin alors c'est dans plus d'un mois
c'est loin vous nous direz pourquoi
cette date est-ce que vous comptez faire
à la CFDT d'ici là 3 députés pour
débattre avec vous ce soir bonsoir Marc
ferrachi et merci d'être là vous êtes
député renaissance des Français établis
en Suisse vous êtes ancien conseiller
social de Jean Castex à Matignon et même
de Muriel Pénicaud c'était un peu avant
souviens des ordonnances de travail vous
êtes économiste de profession du travail
et de l'emploi bonsoir Boris Vallot et
merci d'être avec nous vous présidez le
groupe socialiste à l'Assemblée
nationale membre de la nuit de Pesse et
vous êtes député PS des Landes enfin
bonsoir Stéphane Viry bienvenue vous
êtes député les républicains des Vosges
assez critiques sur la sous forme des
retraites sur le report de l'âge mais
pas au point de voter la censure du
gouvernement c'était le 20 mars dernier
il faut il faut préciser maintenant une
positionnement de chacun des
républicains que l'on reçoit alors avant
de vous laisser débattre messieurs on va
planter le décor comme chaque soir avec
la miss Stéphane blackovski 200 secondes
pour nous dire si l'intertindicale a
encore un bel avenir c'est le chrono de
Blacko pour démarrer tout de suite
et je me retourne bonsoir chers Stéphane
bonsoir Myriam bonsoir mes grand plaisir
de vous retrouver j'espère en forme et
moi je suis un Français moyen j'aime
bien les vacances mais bon il fallait
revenir alors je suis revenu
hier mais si c'est le cas vous avez sans
doute vu des images de violence dans les
titres et c'est presque surprenant parce
que c'était pas vraiment ça l'info du
jour des violences dans les manifs mais
il y en a depuis maintenant je sais pas
5-6 ans minimum le truc inédit c'était
ça bon évidemment c'est pas très
spectaculaire ça fait pas grimper
l'audience mais ce truc là cette image
on ne l'avait pas vu depuis 2009 là CFDT
la CGT FO qui importe mais il réuni pour
une manif du 1er mai c'est du jamais vu
depuis 15 ans donc voilà l'info qu'on a
à retenir d'hier avec un communiqué qui
l'a confirmé ce matin on va pas le lire
en entier d'autant que le titre résume
très bien la position de l'Inter
syndicale en quatre points finalement
toujours uni toujours nombreux toujours
déterminé obtenir leur retrait et
toujours déterminer
pour le progrès social bon sur les deux
premiers points Unis nombreux je pense
qu'il y a pas de contestation il y a pas
des balles la manif d'hier en a fait la
preuve ensuite toujours déterminé pour
le retrait là ça peut paraître un peu
plus surprenant puisque la loi est
promulguée va nous dire j'imagine
monsieur ferdin mais il y a quand même
deux cartes que les syndicats ont encore
dans leur manche c'est d'abord la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
qu'on attend demain qu'il pourrait
autoriser un référendum j'ai cru
comprendre que personne n'y croyait
vraiment mais on attend la décision
demain et puis l'autre carte c'est la
proposition qui a été déposée de loi
donc déposée par l'IoT pour abroger le
recul de l'âge de la retraite à 64 ans
je vous rappelle que la motion de
censure qui a été déposée par les Hot a
été rejeté à neuf ou après donc il y a
du suspense donc c'est pour ça que les
syndicats veulent mettre la pression et
le 6 juin nouvelle mobilisation deux
jours avant ce vote à l'assemblée pour
espérer donc l'abrogation des 64 en
attendant l'assemblée a repris
aujourd'hui c'était pas la peine de
mettre la pression sur les insoumis ils
étaient remontés à bloc on écoute la
question et oui c'est une question
d'Antoine la première ministre même si
on entend pas bien le point
d'interrogation on écoute on ne fait pas
taire le peuple on l'écoute on ne le
méprise pas on le respecte
on lui obéit nous ne céderons pas vous
vouliez en avoir fini le 14 juillet vous
aurez votre prise de la Bâtie vous avez
déjà perdu quand retirez-vous votre
réforme des retraites merci oh c'est
dommage qu'il est bafouillé sur Bastille
parce que sinon c'était vraiment une
super belle tirade mais je suis pas sûr
qu'elle soit du goût de toutes les tous
les syndicats moi je parle sous le
contrôle de Laurent Berger il me semble
que le CFDT a plus envie de poursuivre
le dialogue social que de monter à
l'assaut de la Bastille mais je demande
même pas Laurent Berger je vais plutôt
laisser parler celle qui va lui succéder
au mois de juin Marylise Léon on est
aujourd'hui dans une nouvelle une
nouvelle période où le gouvernement nous
dit on veut renouer le dialogue et on
veut aborder un certain nombre de sujets
pour la CFDT c'est clair que on fera pas
la politique de la chaise vide
alors évidemment c'est là que les choses
pourraient commencer à se compliquer si
la CFDT revient la table de la
négociation pendant ce temps-là les
ultras de la CGT je ne sais pas coupe le
courant bloc des raffineries l'unité
syndicale donc forcément paraîtra un peu
affaibli parce que c'est vrai que les
syndicats sont vraiment bien réunissent
contre la réforme des retraites mais
pour le reste des divisions par exemple
en février a eu un accord important qui
a été signé vers les partenaires sociaux
sur l'intéressement des salariés et bien
la CGT et le seul des cinq syndicats les
plus importants qui disaient non elle
voulait pas d'en parler elle ce n'était
que les salaires qui m'intéressait donc
finalement ce qui tient cette syndicale
bah depuis trois mois c'est le combat
contre la réforme des retraites et la
question que je me pose c'est combien de
temps va durer ce combat parce que une
fois qu'il sera réglé je vois pas
comment l'unité syndicale va tenir mais
bon il y a des bas alors c'est une bonne
question ça merci beaucoup Stéphane
Laurent Berger depuis le temps les 64
ans il y a plus d'unité syndicale c'est
ça qui contient
de ce matin
bien il dit très clairement que d'abord
on je crois que l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales se disent prête
à aller rencontrer la première ministre
leur
laisse entendre mais le laisser entendre
c'est déjà c'est déjà presque le dire et
nous disons que nous allons travailler
des propositions communes et nous
pouvons en travailler un certain nombre
ces concerne certains nombre d'éléments
sur lesquels il faut revenir sur les
ordonnances de 2017 l'obligation de
négociation de l'organisation du travail
comme sujet obligatoire de négociation
dans les entreprises enfin il y en a
plein d'autres comme ça donc au travail
démocratie
c'est qu'on a été très clair et très
transparent les uns avec les autres on
n'est pas en train de créer une seule
organisation syndicale on a des
divergences on sait y compris dans les
derniers mois comporté de façon
différente face à un accord
interprofessionnel avec le patronat face
à la façon d'interpeller les
parlementaires y compris sur la réforme
des retraites mais on a été extrêmement
clair sur un point un point contre les
64 ans et une façon de fonctionner
ensemble loyal où on décide ensemble ce
qu'on fait et on assume ce qu'on a
décidé ensemble pour le Reich chacune
des organisations évidemment sa large
autonomie
vous voulez négocier en tout cas
discuter ensemble vous savez d'ailleurs
comment ça va se passer les invitations
sont pas encore arrivées vous irez
ensemble ou séparément qu'est-ce que
vous préférez comme au-dessus
on respectera ce qui sera décidé décider
par par Matignon ce qui est habituel
c'est plutôt qui est débilatérales avant
une vingtaine multilatérale avec
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
mais ce qu'on a décidé ce matin c'est
qu'on se dise les bilatérales c'est
qu'il se passera ce qui sera discuté
donc vous savez la terre syndical c'est
ni l'unification du syndicalisme en une
seule organisation
ni y compris hier ça a été très
insistant le fait que on finira par
éclater et je pense que ça sera
l'histoire c'est 4 5 derniers mois ce
sera une histoire différente du
syndicaliste qui s'est écrite mais ce
sera aussi finalement un gros plantage
tout un tas d'observateurs depuis le 10
janvier nous disent vous allez éclater
l'Inter syndicale alors je fais circuler
la parole mais le 6 juin je crois de
comprendre qu'il y avait différentes
stratégies plusieurs dates de
manifestation ou une seule dans un mois
c'est quand même assez loin
n'a proposé plusieurs dates de
mobilisation il y a eu
non plus aucune toutes les organisations
ont dit autour de cette date du 8 qui
est effectivement importantes c'est
peut-être la première possibilité
offerte à l'Assemblée nationale de
pouvoir voter pour ou contre cette
réforme des retraites il y en a pas eu
d'autres le 49-3 était je le rappelle
une motion de censure c'était pas un
vote sur le texte
c'est la première encore les députés
maintenant cette déclaration c'est qu'on
va aller voir les députés pour essayer
de les convaincre de voter cette PPL de
poser par le groupe yacht et le 6 on va
avoir une nouvelle journée mobilisation
vous savez il faut tenir compte d'une
chose hier on a le 1er mai le plus
important sur la question sociale depuis
les années 60
le plus important on a eu un premier
maître très important le 1er mai 2002 on
se rappelle pourquoi parce que
Jean-Marie Le Pen est au second tour
avec son présidentiel jamais sur la
question sociale on avait eu un 1er mai
aussi massif avec des taux de
participation des chiffres de
participation dans les villes moyennes
qui étaient incroyables encore une fois
et donc la colère je peux vous le dire y
compris dans les rangs de la CFDT ou les
cortèges étaient encore très nourris
hier à Paris c'était extrêmement
impressionnant jamais la colère a été
aussi forte
d'implanter marque ferrati on va venir
sur la proposition doit du groupe liote
et cette date du 8 juin qui va être
évidemment très importante mais la
colère le mouvement du 1er mai
historique 13 journées de mobilisation
une 14ème à venir l'opinion qui de façon
constante quand même il faut le
souligner le soutien à la contestation
et même comprend les casseroles je vais
pas vous donner des sondages au doxa par
exemple mais ils sont tous dans le même
sens ça doit vous ébranler quand même
dans la majorité non vous n'avez pas
peur de créer profond durable dans le
pays
on fait attention à ce qui se passe dans
la rue la colère elle est là la colère
elle s'est exprimée dans le cadre de 13
journées de mobilisation c'est
je sais pas si c'est historique j'ai pas
la Genèse ni les chiffres en tête
notamment sur ce qui s'est passé en 2010
lors de la précédente réforme qui a
repoussé Las Vegas mais relativise rien
on sait qu'il y a de la colère dans ce
pays on sait que il y a vis-à-vis de
cette réforme une colère qui s'explique
il faut aussi qu'on fasse notre Alger
d'armento qui s'explique par le fait
qu'on a pas réussi à convaincre
d'une part de la nécessité d'une réforme
dont moi je pense que elle est
absolument nécessaire d'une part pour
préserver séparé partition et aussi ça
n'a pas été suffisamment dit pour
dégager des marges de manœuvre
budgétaire pour le reste parce que quand
on travaille plus longtemps
on peut parler d'échecs
de profession et en général quand je ne
réussis pas à expliquer quelque chose à
mes élèves je n'accuse pas mes élèves
j'accuse l'émetteur c'est à dire celui
qui a pris la parole et qui n'a pas
réussi à convaincre donc on a
certainement fait des erreurs moi je
regrette qu'on n'est pas suffisamment
expliqué que derrière cette réforme des
retraites derrière l'idée qu'il fallait
le travail plus nombreux et plus
longtemps il y avait le système de
retraite par répartition mais il y avait
aussi d'autres enjeux parce qu'à un
moment un autre quand vous travaillez
plus nombreux et plus longtemps vous
faites rentrer des impôts qui financent
les services publics qui financent la
transition écologique qui finance
beaucoup de choses et de ça il y a des
rentrées fiscales à côté des cotisations
sociales fléchées exclusivement sur les
retraites qui permettent de financer
autre chose sans prendre l'argent aux
retraiter c'est bien ça pour être bien
clair et finance les retraites c'est
très clair mais quand vous travaillez
plus nombreux et plus longtemps vous
faites rentrer des cotisations retraite
mais aussi des impôts et ces impôts et
financent les services publics je trouve
qu'on ne l'a pas assez dit titre
personnel j'ai essayé de porter ce
message mais ça c'est un élément puis on
n'a pas réussi je vais laisser la parole
à mes collègues on n'a pas réussi à
convaincre aussi de la réalité
tangible concrète pour les Français des
avancées que comporte cette réforme les
avancées sur les carrières longues
aujourd'hui la durée de cotise c'est 42
ans il y a des gens qui travaillent 43 à
44 45 ans demain ce sera 44 pas plus
quand la durée sera à 43 ans c'est une
avancée on peut raconter ce qu'on veut
c'est une avancée sur la pension minimum
là aussi c'est évident que la
communication n'a pas été idéale mais la
réalité c'est que
70 euros en moyenne de plus par mois sur
leur pension donc ça ça laisse des
regrets je moi je le confesse
peut-être que ça laisse des traces dans
l'opinion ensuite dans le pays dans le
pays de la colère notre responsabilité à
nous c'est de reprendre le dialogue de
laisser aussi les partenaires sociaux
dialogués on va en parler parce que moi
je pense qu'il y a des espaces de
dialogue dans lesquels les partenaires
sociaux doivent en autonomie discuter
entre eux et j'espère que c'est comme ça
qu'on reconstruira et bien la confiance
de l'opinion bon bah écoutez la journée
échecs on les entend pas très souvent
dans la bouche de la majorité c'est
peut-être un nouveau discours Boris
Vallot il y a il y a la proposition de
l'alliotte on va y venir parce que
peut-être on ne fait pas mais si le vote
a lieu les la donne pourrait bouger il y
a aussi le rip plus personne n'en parle
le fameux référendum d'initiative
partagée demain simplement pour rebondir
sur ce qui vient d'être dit
les Français ont parfaitement bien
compris la réforme vous l'avez peut-être
c'est peut-être que les mal expliqué
mais je crois que les organisations
syndicales un certain nombre de forces
politiques
75% des Français qui étaient aussi c'est
pas que des gens qui ont pas compris ce
que vous vouliez parce que vous vouliez
faire ici à convaincre ils ont ils ont
parfaitement compris vous n'étiez pas
convaincant parce que la réalité est que
votre réforme était à bien des égards
très injuste et que en réalité ce que
vous n'aviez pas saisi c'est qu'il y
avait dans ce mouvement social quelque
chose qui était plus profond dans ces
sources et sans doute durable dans ses
conséquences que la seule réforme des
retraites c'était au fond le ras-le-bol
de ceux qui n'ont que leur travail pour
vivre et qui arrivent pas en rire et
c'est particulièrement vrai aujourd'hui
avec les augmentations il y a eu des de
de des produits alimentaires qui sont
autour de 15% d'un mois à l'autre avec
des augmentations du SMIC et des minima
sociaux qui ne viendront pas du tout
rattraper ces pertes de pouvoir d'achat
et si cette espèce de ras-le-bol là
c'est franchement ce qu'on a appelé à
20h qui avait cru finalement aux
promesses d'une meilleure reconnaissance
de l'utilité sociale qui se sont vues
une fois de plus passer à la caisse donc
tout le monde bien a bien compris
ensuite la question c'est quelle
conclusion vous en tirez seule
conclusion finalement que vous devriez
en tirer c'est on retire cette réforme
qui est injuste parce qu'elle est un
impôt sur la vie des gens tu sais qu'on
que leur travail pour l'instant
de retrait n'est même pas prononcé
constitutionnel se prononcera sur
deuxième rédaction du référendum
d'initiative justement plus personne
n'en parle on a l'impression que voilà
très peu de chances d'aboutir pourquoi
en quoi ce deuxième référendum cette
deuxième demande dans sa réaction il est
venu il est venu consolider l'idée qu'il
s'agissait bien d'une réforme de
politique sociale c'est l'article 2 sur
le les questions de du financement qui
j'allais dire consolide cette exigence
de l'article 11 de la Constitution je
veux dire que on verra ce qu'est la
réponse demain mais des référendums
d'initiatives partagés sur ce sujet ou
sur des sujets connexes à cette réforme
pourrait en déposer d'autres avec
d'autres rédactions ce que nous avons
lié à travers le
c'est que à un moment donné quand on a
abîmé le dialogue social on a esquivé le
débat parlementaire qu'on n'a pas écouté
les Français qui avait cette aspiration
à cette démocratie continue entre deux
élections il va être entendues a
fortiori quand les conditions de
l'élection du Président de la République
ont testé celles que nous savons et bien
il n'est singe je crois pour un
apaisement général du pays de donner la
parole aux françaises et aux Français
donc évidemment c'est l'espoir que nous
que nous avons demain dans la décision
de concours vous y croyez en un mot
Laurent Berger à ce fameux RIP demain le
Conseil constitutionnel examine une
deuxième demande
n'est pas prise je pense qu'il y a
toujours une possibilité et je le
souhaite je le souhaite je le souhaite
parce que vous savez le pour rebondir
sur ce qu'a dit Monsieur Ferracci je
crois qu'il y a deux problèmes il y a
une déconnexion avec le monde du travail
réel c'est-à-dire que les gens à qui
vous demander de travailler deux ans de
plus y compris ce qui vous bénéfiler des
carrières longues il y aura pas
d'avancées d'avancer s'ils sont leur
avait promis travailler moins parce
qu'il allait travailler plus longtemps
où il travaillait dans les métiers il
y aura pas il y a personne qui a
travaillé moins avant la réforme
certains vont travailler plus mais moins
que ceux qui vont travailler un peu plus
que à cause de l'allongement de la durée
de l'aéroport de l'âge c'est-à-dire la
durée il y avait des gens qui partent en
carrière longue à 60 ans ils vont partir
demain à 62 ans moi j'ai jamais réussi à
expliquer que c'était une avancée pour
les personnes concernées il y a et donc
il y a une forme de déconnexion avec
cette population de qui a été très
impacté au moment du covid et on est
dans un on a ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui
c'est un conflit du travail poste
pandémique personne n'a voulu parler de
ça on n'a pas pu parler du travail et on
va bien d'ailleurs les sujets avec le
gouvernement veut mettre sur la table
maintenant ça concerne le travail mais
après avoir dit vous allez travailler
et regarder le cortège pourquoi il y a
autant de gens dans les villes moyennes
dans les petites villes de province etc
c'est que c'est la réalité la profondeur
l'épaisseur du monde du travail qui se
mobilise dans sa grande diversité c'est
pas des réseaux de militants très très
organisé etc ce sont des citoyens des
travailleurs normaux et qui et qui
viennent dire qu'ils sont en désaccord
et qui ne comprennent pas qu'on leur
fasse payer cette facture là alors
qu'ils ont été là pendant la période
pandémique le deuxième point c'est moi
je je je je c'est l'impasse idéologique
dans lequel c'est mis cette majorité ce
gouvernement on nous dit il faut
travailler plus longtemps parce que ça
va créer plus d'impôts il faut mais vous
c'est tout simplement parce que la la
genèse de ça c'est l'impasse idéologique
oui c'est l'impasse idéologique dans
laquelle s'est mis cette majorité en
expliquant que jamais malgré ce qui
s'était passé malgré on le voit une
contribution
un gain supplémentaire pour tout un tas
de personnes enfin pas tout un tas mais
quelques-uns les très hauts revenus avec
un versement de dividendes qui s'est
accentué etc une inégalité dans les
versements des revenus du travail et qui
qui sait accentué la justice
c'est fondamental et donc expliquer
quand on a 3000 milliards de dettes et
c'est important et ça jamais été un non
sujet pour la CFDT que aller chercher
sur une frange de la population très
particulière du monde du travail les 12
milliards et que c'est ça qui va régler
les problèmes de l'endettement c'est une
fumisterie c'est une fumisterie en plus
d'être une injustice
et puis je vous promet de vous passer la
parole Stéphane virer dans un instant
très rapide absolument pas esquiver
cette cette critique
maintenant si vous commencez à financer
le système de retraite qui est un
système par répartition la répartition
ça veut dire que les actifs
d'aujourd'hui paye la retraite des
retraités d'aujourd'hui et ce système de
répartition on est très attaché si vous
faites financer ce système par l'État
par les impôts par les impôts sur les
personnes par exemple
parce que vous n'avez pas évoqué les
cotisations sur les entreprises mais
c'est important si vous changez la
nature du système
il faut l'assumer nous on n'a pas
souhaité remettre en cause
je vais vous dire jamais je vous ai dit
que tu allais changer la lecture sur ce
système la CFDT elle est très attachée à
la à la répartition ce que vous nous
avez dit tout à l'heure c'est que en
plus ça permettra de financer d'autres
choses il y a d'autres choses de
financement pour financer d'autres
politiques publiques tout à fait
nécessaire en termes de santé vous avez
raison logique vous avez raison nous
avons un déficit de notre système de
retraite qui est aujourd'hui réel à
travers la contribution de l'État au
régime de la fonction publique et qui va
s'accroître dans les prochaines années
on le sait d'ailleurs dans le débat
parlementaire le groupe socialiste
l'admire un moment il y avait un
problème de financement de notre système
de retrait donc il faut quand même le
redire et à un moment ou un autre si on
finance ça par autre chose que les
cotisations et on change de système on
peut avoir cette option c'est pour ça
qu'on voulait pas financer
par une augmentation une contrainte
beaucoup plus forte sur ton emploi des
seniors contrairement à ce qui a été dit
par le Président de la République
lui-même la CFDT a fait tout un tas de
propositions en termes de financement il
y avait des financements en augmentant
le taux soit les seniors potentiellement
en mettant un peu de contraintes sur les
entreprises c'est pas du tout ce qui a
été fait le peu qui a été fait qui était
pas une contrainte ça a été effacé par
le Conseil constitutionnel d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui on lui dit parmi les sujets
qu'il faut sur lesquels on pouvait le
faire en posant la question de la
cotisation des cotisations y compris
employeur et on pouvait le faire
y compris on pouvait le faire avec
contribution
S
n'a pas apporté contrairement à ce que
dit l'exécutif un point final au débat
démocratique la meilleure preuve c'est
la niche parlementaire du 8 juin de nos
colères justement à en croire le
président de ce groupe un peu
hétéroclite le groupe liotte un groupe
centriste à l'Assemblée Bertrand pencher
et bien cette proposition de loi qui
vise à abroger la réforme à des bonnes
chances d'être voté on écoute son
optimisme
il y a 25 députés LR 25-26 qui ont dit
qu'ils allaient qui étaient contre la
retraite donc je pense qu'ils vont venir
voter via des abstentionnistes il suffit
de quelques abstentionnistes une poignée
d'abstentionnistes et dans ce cas-là
cette proposition à tous les chances à
toutes les chances d'être adopté le 8
juin prochain en tout cas nous
l'espérons Stéphane Viry une fois de
plus tous les regards vont se porter le
juillet sur les républicains vous
voterez vous voterez cette proposition
de loi du groupe
son temps on se met en tout cas on
savait que le la promulgation de la loi
mais effectivement à terme juridique un
parcours législatif qui n'était pas le
bon donc avec le sujet politique et
social du pays n'était pas réglée
évidemment sur la question sur les 64
ans il s'agit d'abroger oui ou non
je le dis c'est une parenthèse
importante mais les 100 jours voulu par
Emmanuel Macron si ça cherche à
anesthésier le pays ça fonctionnera pas
le pays ne va pas assez s'endormir il y
a un malaise social qui existe bien
avant ce quinquennat il y a vraiment une
France qui s'interroge sur plein de
sujets c'était pas le moment c'était pas
le moment de mettre la question des
retraites de cette façon à l'agenda
politique maintenant le pays est sous
tension il est même dans une forme
d'impasse il faut en sortir le mouvement
ne doit pas basculer dans la violence on
cherche des bouchers politiques il y a
une proposition de loi à l'Assemblée la
censure a été rejetée de neuf voix vous
pensez que ce sera le même rapport de
force où il a changé je ne sais pas je
ne sais pas je pense qu'il y a trois
choses la première chose c'est un
dialogue il faut que le pays se reparle
Emmanuel Macron a parlé à peu près deux
semaines une partie des français veut
pas l'entendre une autre partie le
concert comme un menteur peu importe
mais me semble-t-il la parole présentiel
elle devait arriver un instant donné
elle vaut ce qu'elle vaut mais il
fallait qu'il parle et c'est peut-être
l'émergence d'une reprise de discussion
de dialogue on y échappera pas me
semble-t-il la deuxième chose c'est
respecter le champ démocratique et les
institutions en tout cas moi je
m'inscris dans le respect de notre façon
d'aide d'une façon de faire certains ne
pensent pas comme moi mais qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire ça aujourd'hui quand on a
une proposition de loi les démocratique
et j'en arrive effectivement
on dit il faut maintenant du contenu du
concret cette proposition de loi a
supposé qu'elle soit votée à l'Assemblée
on va dire les choses il faut pas non
plus que les Français soient dupés à
supposer qu'elle soit voter à
l'assemblée pensez-vous à l'instant quel
sera simplement fixée à l'ordre du Sénat
et qu'elle pourrait être votée au Sénat
donc ça signifie qu'effectivement ça
permet parce que le Sénat de droite a
déjà sur la table et j'en suis ravi
parce que le 8 juin on va pouvoir faire
ce qu'on n'a pas pu faire en février à
savoir parler du financement de notre
système de protection sociale et du
travail en général donc moi je suis ravi
qu'on évoque le sujet le 8 juin mais
même à supposer que ce soit voté je ne
sais pas qui pourrait la voter cette
propositions que la messédite et que les
64 ans soient brogés combien même marque
ferrarachi on avance sur le fond de la
suite du dialogue social ce serait une
claque à l'Assemblée ainsi ce vote cette
abrogation était votée est-ce que vous
êtes député de la majorité vous allez
laisser faire ce débat est-ce que vous
souhaitez évidemment pas que le
collaboration et soit voté mais que le
vote puisse avoir lieu et moi toutes les
solutions qui s'agissent de référendum
d'initiative partagée ou qu'il s'agisse
d'une proposition de loi qui s'inscrit
dans le cadre de nos institutions
elles sont légitimes et je ne les
contesterai jamais donc il faut qu'on
ait ce débat même si on a passé
suffisamment de temps dans un débat qui
était assez ruptif et objectivement pas
très fertile sur la réforme des
retraites parce qu'il y avait de
l'obstruction de la part des oppositions
mais moi j'ai pas de problème avec ça je
faisais partie des députés qui
souhaitaient qu'on aille au vote qui ne
souhaitait pas le 49,3 parce que j'étais
convaincu qu'en réalité on pouvait
gagner ce vote on saura jamais on le
saura jamais mais la réalité c'est que
on ne s'abaisse jamais à débattre et on
ne s'abaisse jamais à voter ma
conviction on verra bien donc le 6 et le
8 juin en attendant je le disais le
gouvernement espère renouer le dialogue
social quel dialogue social quelle
méthode quelle priorité voici ce que
l'on sait du calendrier des mois à venir
c'est signé Diane karcher
pour désamorcelets
si on vous invite pour désamorcer la
contestation le gouvernement veut jouer
la carte de l'apaisement avec un texte
consensuel fin mai la transposition de
l'accord de partage de la valeur signée
par les organisations patronales et
syndicales quand elles font des
bénéfices les PME de 11 à 49 salariés
vont désormais de voir leur en reverser
une partie avec l'espoir de faire
progresser leur pouvoir d'achat mais ce
n'est qu'une parenthèse avant un dossier
explosif le projet de loi pleine emploi
présenté début juin en conseil des
ministres un texte pour encadrer la
réforme de Pôle Emploi désormais
baptisée France travail et doté de
compétences élargies mais aussi celle du
RSA au programme 15 à 20h par semaine
d'activités d'insertion obligatoire pour
percevoir la location le ministre du
Travail Olivier du soft prépare déjà le
terrain ça peut être des choses très
classiques de
la formation de des ateliers de réponse
à des offres d'emploi de rédaction de CV
nous connaissons tout cela ça peut être
aussi des activités et un parcours
personnalisé pour lever des freins donc
nous sommes très loin vous le voyez du
travail obligatoire du travail gratuit
du bénévolat obligatoire à plus long
terme l'exécutif planche sur un nouveau
projet de loi travail syndicat et
patronat sont d'abord invités à négocier
jusqu'au 14 juillet pour déterminer le
contenu du nouveau pacte de vie au
travail promis par Emmanuel Macron CDI
seniors et index seniors initialement
prévu dans la réforme des retraites
pourrait faire leur retour et de leur
côté les syndicats veulent avancer
runnis notamment sur les salaires les
conditions de travail ou encore la
démocratie sociale un gros dossier qui
pourrait être atterrir à l'Assemblée en
février 2024 dans près d'un an pas sûr
que cette perspective suffise à calmer
la colère sociale
Laurent Berger vous avez compris les
choses comme ça sur la méthode de textes
à très court terme en juin partage de la
valeur France travail avec le fameux RSA
sous conditions et puis on construit
ensemble voir au co-construit un agenda
social pour l'instant pour la CFDT ce
qui sera clair c'est qu'il y aura deux
de préalables à des discussions sincères
la première c'est la le premier
préalable c'est la méthode la méthode si
il s'agit de venir commenter un document
que la presse a déjà en amont et sur
lequel on fait deux trois amendements on
pèse pas ça n'a pas de sens ça n'a pas
de sens et j'ai envie de dire on a déjà
donné une certaine manière donc nous on
veut une vraie co-construction et on
veut que à chaque proposition apportée
par les organisations syndicales et par
la CFDT en particulier il soit fait
objection ou non mais ça soit commenté
ce qui n'a pas été fait sur les
retraites notre cocktail de mesure sur
les financements elle a été le geste a
quasiment été ça non parce qu'on va
faire les 60 personnes
il y aura un sujet de contenu de contenu
la colère sociale c'est pas avec les
mesures solaires et ça dont on peut
craindre beaucoup beaucoup de populisme
sur le sujet en direction des personnes
qui sont bénéficiaires du RSA et c'est
pas sur une nouvelle organisation
deux Pôle Emploi etc qui peut avoir du
sens en termes de fonctionnement mais
enfin qui va pas apporter la réponse à
la colère sociale qui est importée donc
qu'il y ait du temps pour construire une
loi qui s'appellera loi travail ou loi
d'accord mais nous ce qu'on veut dedans
c'est des choses sur les conditions de
travail on veut que les conditions de
travail l'organisation du travail soit
un sujet obligatoire de négociation dans
l'entreprise ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui on veut revenir sur les
ordonnances de 2017 pour remettre
notamment la question des conditions de
travail mais aussi des représentants de
proximité sur la table on a 11
propositions sur les ordonnances 2017 on
veut que sur la question salariale il y
a une conditionnalité des aides
publiques versées aux entreprises
notamment sur les bas salaires
qui soient conditionné au fait qu'il n'y
ait aucune branche qui soit en dessous
du SMIC sur son premier échelon
aujourd'hui suite à la revalorisation du
SMIC du 1er mai il y a 151 branches sur
171 qui ont des échelons inférieurs au
SMIC ça veut dire que vous pouvez être
dans cette branche là payer au SMIC mais
pendant 10 ans ou 15 ans avant de
rattraper les échelons
ce soir ce que je veux dire c'est que
soit on est dans une vraie logique de
faire évoluer aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe dans le monde du travail en terme
de répartition de la richesse en terme
de conditions de travail en terme de
conditions d'emploi en termes de
dialogue social et on va pouvoir ouvrir
les discussions soit il y a quelques
mesurettes technocratiques qui sont
avancées et il y aura pas débouchés pour
nous qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça la
co-construction la méthode avec
clairement les ordonnances de 2017 dont
vous êtes en partie l'auteur il faut le
rappeler avec avec Muriel Pénicaud au
ministère du Travail les salaires et
aucune branche au-dessus au dessous du
SMIC et les conditions de travail la
co-construction et puis il y a
négociation moi j'ai entendu des
partenaires sociaux syndicats et
patronat dans les derniers mois appelé
sur un certain nombre de sujets à
devrait négociations c'est-à-dire des
négociations entre eux leur donner un
champ ou des champs des thèmes sur
lesquels ils peuvent se mettre d'accord
sur le sujet des conditions de travail
sur le sujet de l'usure professionnelle
sur le sujet qui échange le sait à la
CDT du compte épargneau universel comme
on articule mieux les temps personnel et
professionnels moi je pense que ce sont
des objets de négociation entre les
partenaires sociaux et il me semble que
la logique dans laquelle se situe le
gouvernement c'est justement d'ouvrir
ces espaces de négociation ensuite les
partenaires sociaux choisiront d'y aller
ou de pas y aller mais à un moment un
autre il faut choisir est-ce qu'on
demande à l'état de faire les réformes
ou est-ce que on soutient le principe
d'une négociation moi je pense que ce
sont des objets de négociation et
j'espère que les partenaires sociaux
vont s'en saisir ensuite et bien on
verra comment ça aboutit mais ce que je
peux vous dire et ça va être le cas sur
l'accord sur le partage de la valeur sur
lequel j'ai travaillé avec un certain
nombre de mes collègues la participation
d'autres propositions il y a 35
propositions 35 articles dans cette dans
cet accord national je peux vous dire
que ça va être transposé de manière
extrêmement fidèle et que si les
partenaires sociaux se mettent sur ce
paquet qu'on appelle la loi travail avec
des négociations qui aboutissent à des
accords si c'est la méthode qui est
proposée par la première ministre et
bien je peux vous dire que dans la
majorité présidentielle et bien on
soutiendra la transposition de ses actes
dire que on a une situation à
l'Assemblée nationale qui est inédite
une majorité relative un parlementarisme
de fait
issu des urnes c'est ici à l'assemblée
que les compromis les majorités doivent
se construire et moi je dis à la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale mais
vous portez cette proposition ensemble
faisons ici aussi à l'Assemblée
nationale la grande conférence sociale
sur tous les sujets qui intéressent les
partenaires sociaux construisons si on
est capable de le faire un certain
nombre de majorités autour de ce qui
préoccupe les Français et
leur représentants
au retour des syndicats
légitimité n'est pas de se mettre
d'accord au préalable
il peut y avoir un accord national
interprofessionnel qu'ensuite nous
transcrivons dans la loi qu'on peut
enrichir sur un certain nombre d'aspects
vous savez que pour ce qui concerne les
socialistes les écarts de rémunération
par exemple sont des sujets de
préoccupation pas dédiés de la question
de la gouvernance d'entreprise je crois
savoir qu'il y avait que les
organisations syndicales de ce point de
vue là quelques points de quelques
points de convergence je dis juste que
dans le moment où nous sommes il y a un
appétit de débat démocratique de de
dialogue social il faut qu'il y a
évidemment se dialogue social entre les
partenaires sociaux mais que nous
pouvons ici à l'Assemblée nationale qui
doit être le cœur battant de notre
démocratie construire ces grands moments
de consensus républicain dont on a été
capable dans l'histoire c'est le
gouvernement qui aujourd'hui est bloqué
et bloque le pays parce qu'il refuse de
retrait ici à l'Assemblée nationale ça
continue de respirer sur le plan
démocratique c'est difficile c'est
compliqué on a des désaccords mais enfin
on n'a jamais opposé au développement je
fais cette proposer aussi d'aller un peu
plus vite en faisant différents projets
de loi qui pourraient être voté avant
2021 des lois immortels parlent après
santé cette possibilité d'un changement
de méthode ou pas il y a des recours
possibles évidemment la négociation
interprofessionnelle à une console
condition c'est qu'il y ait pas des
lettres de cadrage comme ça a été
l'habitude dans les dernières années qui
sont tellement contraignantes que
finalement il y a plus d'espace à
négociation et puis à l'autre condition
c'est que sur un certain nombre de
sujets on sache le comportement du
gouvernement
si jamais il y a pas un corps c'est à
dire que nous soyons pas hypocrite sur
les ordonnances Macron si on retourne à
négociation le patronat ne bougera pas
est-ce que la majorité est prête à
bouger est-ce que la majorité est prête
à comprendre que suite à la pandémie le
fait qu'il y ait plus de représentante
proximité dans les entreprises c'est une
catastrophe
que de pas avoir une commission santé
sécurité au travail dans toutes les
entreprises et pas simplement dans celle
de plus de 300 c'est une catastrophe
bien de publier un rapport et donc et
donc je pense que il faut ça peut le
paradiger une conférence sociale mais il
faut qu'on fixe le cadre des avancées
possibles dans le monde du travail mais
pour que chacun se sente sous contrainte
en tout cas c'est pas si Stéphane Viry
vous vous participerez à droite ou votre
d'accord par exemple de la valeur ça ça
va de soi vous avez vu l'état du pays
latence les tensions le malaise il faut
bien qu'on en sorte et je l'ai dit dans
un champ démocratique il nous reste
quatre ans dans ce quinquennat et il n'y
a pas de majorité absolue comment
fait-on que chacun assume ses
responsabilités qu'on part effectivement
de l'assemblée et qu'ensemble on cherche
à répondre aux enjeux du pays de la
transition écologique la dette le
partage de la valeur le travail on n'a
pas d'autre choix me semble-t-il que
d'être bon collectivement pour éviter
que Madame Le Pen ne soit au pouvoir je
crois que la donne elle est là c'est pas
une question de Macron pas Macron il est
là pendant 4 ans moi je me moi quand je
raisonne par rapport à projet de loi je
raisonne pas par rapport à Emmanuel
Macron je raisonne d'une part par
rapport à la France et par rapport à ce
que je veux aller dans les quatre mois
le sujet pour moi il est là bon
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez dire à ceux
qui nous regardent et qui sont en colère
qui ont fait beaucoup de manifestations
Marc ferrachi sur la suite pour leur
dire au fond on a peut-être pris les
choses à l'envers mais on va essayer de
les remettre à l'endroit
je pense que ce qui a montré notre
discussion ce soir c'est qu'on va se
remettre à parler de travail
sérieusement et je prends le point qui
était celui de Laurent Berger en méthode
avec adresse de discussion pour les
partenaires sociaux mais c'est ce que je
souhaite et je souhaite que le débat
pour faire écho aussi est-ce que dit
Boris Vallaud se poursuivre à
l'assemblée de manière un peu plus
apaisée quand même que ce que nous avons
vécu dans la réforme des retraites merci
beaucoup on va s'arrêter là on aurait pu
continuer longtemps c'était passionnant
merci la suite on va évidemment la vivre
au quotidien et sur LCP il y a le 6 il y
a le 8 il y a deux mains le rip le
Conseil constitutionnel va faire
connaître sa décision merci messieurs
vous restez avec moi Laurent Berger dans
une dizaine de minutes vous les voyez
ils sont fin prêts nos affranchis pour
leur partie prix Fanny guinochet ce soir
va vous interpeller Laurent Berger sur
les rémunérations des grands patrons qui
explosent après le covid Richard Berly
va revenir sur les conséquences de la
dégradation de la note de la France par
l'agence
et puis Stéphanie Despierre dans Bourbon
Express nous raconte l'audition de
François Fillon par la commission
d'enquête sur l'ingérence des puissances
étrangères mais d'abord on va parler un
peu de vous de votre parcours près de 11
ans à la tête de la CFDT on ne quitte
pas en tout cas la tête d'une
organisation comme ça sans forcément
quelques émotions retour en archives sur
les temps forts de votre engagement
syndical avec Hélène Bonduelle
[Applaudissements]
si on vous invite Laurent Berger c'est
parce que ce défilé du 1er mai sur fond
de réforme des retraites avait un goût
un peu particulier pour vous je pense
que la dans un an je serai un peu plus
loin ou je serai ailleurs mais je serai
toujours là je suis toujours à mi-temps
après 11 ans à la tête de la CFDT vous
avez choisi de passer la main
particulière je suis heureux d'être là
Marie lisez là Marylise Léon c'est celle
qui vous succédera dans quelques
semaines
Laurent Berger avec des parents en
cdtistes vous tombez très jeunes dans le
syndicalisme à 25 ans militant à la
Jeunesse ouvrière chrétienne vous
défendez déjà les jeunes apprentis et
leurs conditions de travail c'est votre
première télé on connaît beaucoup de
jeunes qui parlent après apprentissage
ont renonçait un apprentissage parce
qu'il faisait 45 heures chez un
employeur ils étaient pas payés ou alors
50 francs par-ci par là pour faire
plaisir on Trenton vous avez gravi les
échelons à la
manuel Macron et vous c'est peu dire que
la relation est tendue certains dans la
majorité présidentielle vous prête des
ambitions politiques une partie de la
gauche vous rêve même candidat à la
présidentielle mais ce sera non point
final répétez-vous unlassablement alors
Laurent Berger vous qui terminez
l'écriture d'un essai sur le travail
apparaître mi-mai si c'était ça votre
ambition politique que ce livre soit la
base d'un programme présidentiel pour la
gauche en 2027
réponse Laurent Berger dans ce livre
c'est un essai sur le travail à partir
de mon expérience de ce que j'ai pu voir
dans les nombreuses rencontres avec les
salariés et c'est j'espère une source
d'inspiration pour tous ceux qui pensent
que le travail est encore un élément
structurant aujourd'hui pour pour les
citoyens mais qu'il mérite des pensées
qu'il méritent d'être
reconnu que les travailleurs et
travailleuses ne sont pas une force
productive uniquement ce sont des
travails et moi mon rôle jusqu'à lors ça
a été un rôle syndical demain je
disparais pas
disparaître je vais être plus discret
mais je veux continuer à travailler sur
ces enjeux du travail ces enjeux de la
démocratie et être utile en termes
d'idées et à ceux qui voudront bien les
saisir alors on va pas égrainer tout
l'album de vos onze années à la tête de
la CFDT mais quel est votre plus belle
victoire de quoi êtes-vous le plus fier
après ces 11 années est-ce que est-ce
que c'est ce moment que nous vivons et
cette unité syndicale dont vous vous
êtes un peu l'architecte aussi il y
aurait beaucoup à dire de ces 11 années
c'est des années traversées de moments
sociaux énormes il y a eu le moment on a
eu covid où il a fallu maintenant une
organisation syndicale des propositions
faire en sorte que personne ne soit
oublié dans les protections qui ont été
construites à ce moment-là forcément on
est devenu la première organisation
syndicale là je suis extrêmement fier on
est une organisation qui aujourd'hui
dans ces instances dirigeantes et à
parité totale et ça nous permet d'avoir
une future secrétaire général je suis
très fier de ça aussi je suis très fier
oui cette première place très fier de
d'avoir parcouru je crois à peu près
tous les départements français à la
rencontre des salariés et d'avoir obtenu
quelques belles victoires la
complémentaire santé pour les salariés
du privé payer à 50% par l'employeur
l'extension de la garantie jeune enfin
je pourrais en citer plein sans parler
des combats locaux
des échecs des échecs je crois que cette
fameuse négociation sur la modernisation
du dialogue social qu'on a sur laquelle
on n'arrive pas à aller au bout parce
que une vision du patronat et logique de
réduction du dialogue et du coup du
dialogue social et qui emmène le
lendemain enfin à quelques années après
les ordonnances les ordonnances travail
donc oui c'est traversé aussi de ça puis
c'est traversé le tristesse aussi la
disparition de François cherreg de mon
collègue Frédéric Seb donc c'est une vie
10 ans c'est quand même un moment des
moments importants et donc c'est tout ça
qui fait ce syndicat aujourd'hui dans
cette bataille pas du tout c'est que la
CFDT réformiste avec cette culture du
compromis cette culture des équilibres
et du dialogue certains disent qu'elle
s'est un peu radicalisée vous savez je
crois que il faudrait regarder mais je
crois que je suis secrétaire général qui
est assigné le plus d'accord
interprofessionnels
durant ces 11 années presque j'ai
commencé des janvier 2013 un mois et
demi deux mois après secrétaire général
de la CFDT en signant l'accord sur la
modernisation du travail c'est la
situation de l'emploi pardon parce que
2008 c'est de l'emploi avec de vraies
avancées non et vous savez je reste un
adepte du dialogue social je reste un
adepte du compromis mais le syndicalisme
c'est porter une critique sociale porter
des propositions et revendications
savoir s'engager dans des négociations
et des compromis puis contester quand on
n'est pas d'accord il y a un truc qui
n'aura pas bougé chez moi c'est la
version elle nous injustices sociales
c'est la version inégalités et quand
elles sont là en conteste alors il y a
le recul de l'âge que vous avez toujours
combattu et aussi le président de la
République avec lequel vous n'avez pas
eu des rapports faciles et ce quasiment
depuis le début dès 2017 vous avez dit
aux journalistes du Monde Laurent Tello
qui vous a consacré un long portrait
c'est psychanalytique au bout d'un
moment le rapport qu'émanuel Macron a
avec moi qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
rapport là vous avez compris d'abord moi
j'ai jamais voulu résumer ça un combat
entre deux hommes pour une raison simple
c'est d'abord on n'est pas au même
fonction il y a le président de la
République c'est la fonction suprême
dans notre pays moi je me prends pas
pour ce que je ne suis pas je suis le
responsable de la première
reconnaissance vocale de ce pays je
crois qu'il y a l'impression que c'est
devenu il y a des accords entre vous non
non non
pratique lui je dis alors j'ai jamais
cité il y a une crise démocratique il y
a une crise démocratique je suis pas le
seul à l'avoir oui bien sûr je l'assume
j'essaie de particularité d'assumer à
peu près ce que j'exprime parce que
j'essaie de le faire avec mesure il y a
une crise démocratique je n'ai pas
attaqué j'ai pas compris je vous le dis
franchement qu'à deux reprises à deux
reprises c'est à dire dans une
intervention au trésor pendant la crise
des retraites et puis ensuite dans un
offre qui est devenu un on dans un
voyage en Chine il s'en prennent
énormément à moi et à la CFDT ça n'a pas
de sens quand on sait le rôle de la CFDT
peut avoir y compris pour sortir d'une
forme de crise sociale mais au-delà de
ça moi j'ai pas de problème personnel
avec le président de la République j'ai
un problème conception qui est double un
impensé de sa part je crois sur ce
qu'elle a démocratie sociale et le rôle
du syndicalisme qui ne se cantonne pas à
simplement l'entreprise mais qui a aussi
une vision globale sur le sauter il y a
une deuxième c'est le rapport qu'on peut
avoir aux inégalités sociales au fait
que il y a dans notre pays comme partout
dans toute société des personnes qu'on
qui mérite d'être accompagnées de façon
plus forte et que ça ne peut pas être
simplement être toi et la chance
t'aidera si son rapport au corps
intermédiaire change à l'avenir on sait
que c'est pas forcément sa tasse de thé
alors vous partez au moment où les
syndicats sont de retour en grâce plus
30 000 adhésion à la CFDT d'ailleurs
comme à la CGT un depuis
35000 depuis janvier dernier vous pensez
que c'est durable ce regain du
syndicalisme je crois que le
syndicalisme sort renforcé de cette
période même si on malheureusement on
regrette pour l'instant la promulgation
de cette loi mais je crois que c'est du
si on est capable de toujours parler à
hauteur de femmes et d'hommes des
réalités de travail et c'est la force de
la CFDT la CFDT a assumé une forme de de
leadership avec d'autres dans ce
mouvement dans ce mouvement social tout
simplement parce qu'on présente
l'épaisseur du bon du travail et y
compris ces professions dont on parlait
jamais jusqu'à l'heure et donc dont on
parle aujourd'hui parce qu'elles étaient
là pendant pendant le confinement et
donc oui ça peut être durable si on a
une ambition c'est d'être utile être
utile au travailleur d'apporter des
avancées par des compromis par des
résultats dans l'entreprise jusqu'au
niveau national donc je suis je suis
confiant je pars au moment de la CFDT et
la première organisation syndicale est
très en forme un regain d'adhésion un
regain de création de section syndicale
mais je pars justement parce que on a
des pratiques démocratiques qui font
qu'au bout d'une dizaine d'années on
part et j'ai une éthique personnelle qui
est que je n'aime pas ma propriété les
choses collectives et qu'une
organisation syndicale c'est quelque
chose de collectif et que y compris la
personnalisation de ces derniers mois
c'était on va regarder une dernière
image avant de découvrir cet entretien
les unes les nombreuses une que vous
avez fait dans dans la presse tout ça ça
va pas ça va pas vous manquer est-ce
qu'on l'a cette image les voilà les
interviews trois médias par jour la
lumière au fond le fait que je vais vous
dire tout à l'heure même votre votre
responsable de la programmation quand
elle est venue me chercher Elise ça va
vous manquer et de façon assez spontanée
je dis non en fait je vais être très
franc moi je suis un produit du
collectif de l'éducation populaire je
suis plutôt timide et réservé et ce qui
va me manquer c'est le contact avec les
militants et les militantes je
l'exercerai j'espère de façon différente
mais oui non je sais ça fait partie de
la responsabilité j'ai entretenu de
bonnes relations respectueuses avec
l'ensemble des journalistes parce que
c'est ma façon d'être mais voilà je vais
passer à autre chose et je vais voir
plus de temps pour lire plus de temps à
consacrer au mien et et à faire d'autres
choses donc non je voilà j'aime bien ces
discussions je veux pas cracher dans la
soupe du tout au contraire qui va vous
manquer de plus on a bien compris
et vous revenez avec le livre absolument
allez vous restez avec moi c'est l'heure
de des parties pris nos affranchis vont
vous interpeller on les accueille tout
de suite on est très en retard Fanny Guy
nochez c'est parti de France Info comme
chaque matin pour le décryptage écho
Richard werli regards européens du
quotidien suisse biblique bonsoir à tous
les deux on va commencer avec Bourbon
Express comme chaque soir l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée nous est racontée ce
soir par Stéphanie des pierres bonsoir
Stéphanie bonsoir et l'histoire du jour
c'est le retour à l'Assemblée d'un
ancien candidat à la présidentielle d'un
ancien Premier ministre François Fillon
oui François Fillon l'ancien premier
c'était convoqué cet après-midi devant
la commission d'enquête sur les
ingérences étrangères en France il ne
pouvait pas se dérober ou à
l’interrogation des députés qui se
demandent si François Fillon est un
agent de l'influence russe en France car
que car depuis longtemps il a noué une
relation étroite avec la Russie
l'émission en complément d'enquête sur
France Télévisions estime même qu'il a
des relations personnelles avec Vladimir
Poutine et surtout depuis novembre 2021
il rejoint le conseil d'administration
de deux entreprises russes une de
pétrochimie contre les parents proches
de Vladimir Poutine et une dydrocarbure
qui appartient à l'État russe à l'hiver
2022 au comble de la tension entre
l'Ukraine et la Russie il refusaient de
démissionner les critiques fusées et
finalement il l'aura démissionné mais au
lendemain seulement de l'attaque contre
l'Ukraine donc voilà pour le contexte
oui et pour l'audition audition feutrée
ambiance comment dire précautionneuse
des députés qui interrogaient presque
révérendes des députés qui interrogaient
l'ancien Premier ministre Premier
ministre toujours tiré à quatre épingles
très à l'aise très posée et qui s'est
expliqué j'ai toujours défendu l'intérêt
national a-t-il dit et il s'est défendu
clairement non il n'y avait pas
d'ingérence malgré ça
malgré sa présence à ses conseils
d'administration et cela pour trois
raisons écouter
la première raison c'est que c'est moi
qui suis allé en Russie pour développer
mes activités professionnelles en Russie
avant la déclaration de la guerre et
donc c'est pas les Russes qui sont venus
me chercher la deuxième raison c'est que
les entreprises où j'ai accepté dans
lesquels j'ai accepté de sierger sont
des entreprises pour lesquelles il n'y a
pas de relation stratégiques avec la
France aucune et la troisième raison
mais là il faudra me croire sur parole
c'est que mon parcours
montre que je ne suis pas sensible aux
ingérences étrangères
et François Fillon pardon a précisé
qu'il n'avait pas touché un centime en
provenance de Russie puisqu'il a
expliqué qu'il n'avait participé qu'à un
seul déconseille d'administration de
chaque entreprise et qu'après donc il
avait démissionné la gauche a été
attendée d'être plus en offensive mais
son succès François Fillon a balayé tous
les arguments en revanche il s'est fait
très offensif pour défendre son droit à
une carrière professionnelle après la
politique je tiens d'ailleurs à préciser
que cette guerre professionnelle ne
regarde que moi que je n'ai de compte à
rendre à personne sur la manière dont je
la conduis dans le respect naturellement
des lois de la République et des
intérêts et des règlements européens je
suis une personne privée depuis 2017 si
j'ai envie de vendre des rillettes sur
la place sur la Place Rouge je vendrai
des rillettes sur la Place Rouge
et il a démenti à tout accusation de
liens personnels avec Vladimir Poutine
je ne l'ai jamais participé il m'a fait
une manifestation privée et il a surtout
pris soin de ne pas communiquer la
politique actuelle de la France à
l'égard de la Russie il a reconnu une
seule chose je me suis trompé sur un
point je le reconnais j'étais convaincu
que Vladimir Poutine ne passerait pas à
l'acte manière encore de justifier qu'il
n'avait pas démissionner avant l'attaque
merci beaucoup Stéphanie ambiance
feutrée un peu un peu tendu on a senti
dans cette audition Fanny Fanny
guinocchio nous parlait des salaires des
augmentations des rémunérations des
grands patrons en ce moment c'est
l'heure des assemblées générales Air
France ben Smith le patron d'Air France
KLM devrait toucher jusqu'à 5 millions
d'euros cette année augmentation 5 fois
plus élevée qu'en 2021 et ça c'est
possible et bien par parce que la
compagnie a remboursé les aides d'État
du covid et si bien ce qui pose problème
les aides d'État parce que pour
augmenter ses dirigeants donc Air France
devait rembourser certes la compagnie a
pu le faire elle a ép fait ses comptes
les aides d'État qu'il y avait c'était
le chômage partiel je vais pas toutes
les lister mais aussi de jolis prêts et
garantis par l'État et avec la reprise
du trafic et bien les comptes sont
revenus dans le verre mais et ben Smith
bingo peut s'augmenter jusqu'à même 5
fois plus que en 2021 alors ce qu'il y a
c'est que sans ces aides d'État et bien
la compagnie serait certainement à terre
puisque
Air France comme de nombreuses
entreprises ont été aidées pendant mais
aussi après le covid et qu'aujourd'hui
quand on regarde et bien l'inflation est
forte Air France ne baisse pas ses
billets d'avion bien au contraire la
compagnie fait le choix d'augmenter ses
dirigeants et ben Smith le patron d'Air
France n'est pas le seul non quand vous
regardez c'est un peu la fête cette
année parce que 2022 a été une
excellente année parce que toutes ces
entreprises en tout cas si on regarde
celles du CAC 40 ont très bien sortent
très bien leur épine pieds en tirent
leur épingle du jeu parce que
était soutenu pendant l'année 21 par les
millions d'euros du quoi qu'il en coûte
et c'est vrai que vous pouvez regarder
par exemple stellantis Carlos tavaron
plus de 20 millions d'euros de
rémunération cette année alors que
l'entreprise l'a aussi se constructeur
automobile a pu bénéficier d'un soutien
sans faille de l'État y compris encore
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui quand il manque
des semis conducteurs des pièces dans
les usines l'entreprise telantis mais en
chômage partiel financé par l'État et si
on veut être un peu plus précis même par
une partie de l'assurance chômage et
bien c'est l'État qui paye alors comment
faire est-ce qu'on peut laisser faire
alors les patrons eux ils expliquent que
ils sont soumis à une concurrence
internationale des talents que il y a un
code affecte Medef qui régule tout ça
mais il y a pas de sanction c'est un
code de bonne conduite mais on voit bien
quand même que ces petits sujets passent
mal dans l'opinion surtout en ce moment
alors que les Français ont du mal à
joindre les deux bouts alors est-ce
qu'il faudrait conditionnaliser ces
aides d'État les maîtres sous conditions
on parle beaucoup du quelqu'un dans
l'emploi on parle des respects des
normes environnementales est-ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas aussi un peu d'éthique
salarial vous avez deux trois secondes
vous êtes choqués évidemment
pour une part c'est un descend deux la
puissance publique elle a la moyenne
alors à partir du moment inverse des
aides d'avoir des considéralités des
aides publiques y compris sur les
écarteurs vénération c'est les
augmentations
sans doute cette fameuse agenda social
c'est sur la table Richard on termine
avec vous le temps presse 3 minutes
chrono pour nous dire si l'agence Fitch
qui a dégradé légèrement notre note de
AAA à moins et bien nous a pas rendu
finalement un petit service salutaire
non c'est ce que vous pensez alors
effectivement moi j'ai été frappé par
l'expression de Bruno Le Maire qui
aussitôt a dégainé en disant qu'il est
en désaccord complet avec la vie de
Fitch feat je le rappelle quand même
c'est la troisième agence de notation et
elle a appartenu longtemps un français
Marc l'adré de la Charrière qu'il a
revendu ses parents 2018 pour 3
milliards d'euros
juste au passage et bien quand on lit la
vie de Fitch et quand on le lit sur le
site de l'agence de notation c'est
facile c'est en anglais mais les
logiciels de traduction permettent on
s'aperçoit de quoi on s'aperçoit bien
évidemment il y a une préoccupation ça
n'étonne pas de la part d'une agence de
notation sur les dépenses publiques
c'est habituel Fitch je pense que
l'adoption récente de la réforme des
retraites sera modérément positive et
que l'impasse politique et les
mouvements sociaux entre parenthèses
parfois violents constituent un risque
et pour écrire encore plus de pression
en faveur d'une politique budgétaire
expansionniste en clair ça veut dire que
ce n'est pas comme ça que la France
parviendra à se réformer la voix
empruntée n'est pas la bonne autrement
dit prière au gouvernement de réviser sa
copie il y a une autre leçon attirer
alors effectivement il y a une deuxième
leçon qui à mon avis est encore plus
intéressante pour les partenaires
européens de la France il s'agit de
l'évaluation parfaite du parcours depuis
plusieurs années du pays c'est-à-dire en
gros sous le premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron et là il y a un mot
qui revient l'absence d'un
assainissement financier budgétaire
suffisant celui-ci n'a pas suivi à
empêcher une augmentation continue de la
dette par rapport aux produits intérieur
brut c'est assainissement est
incompatible avec les solides
indicateurs structurels alors il y a du
jargon économique mais l'important c'est
que pour l'agence de notation la France
est frappée par un niveau d'endettement
élevé et que la combinaison ressource
recette dépense du gouvernement depuis 5
ans n'est tout simplement pas la bonne
alors on comprend pourquoi Bruno Le
Maire est en désaccord complet avec
Fitch et bien c'est parce que c'est
aussi son bilan et celui du gouvernement
qui est pointé du doigt allez une
dernière réaction on a le temps un tout
petit peu de temps le berger c'est la
capacité de la France à faire des
réformes structurelles qui est mise en
cause par cette agence à l'avenir
structurelles se font avec les citoyens
avec les travailleurs et travailleuses
et pas en expliquant on va en disant on
va vous expliquer en groupe d'après
point de vue macro enfin je crois que
c'est le vrai drame en fait c'est qu'il
faut les faire à hauteur de femmes et
d'hommes et d'expliquer qu'il y a des
choses nécessaires y compris pour
réduire l'endettement public mais que ça
ne peut pas mais bien sûr il faut prier
pour quelque chose de grand public la
CFDT c'est toujours engagée pour les
formes des retraites lorsque c'était
juste il y avait des éléments de justice
mais sans justice on réforme pas et on
peut pas en vouloir aux Français
merci à vous merci d'être venu sur le
plateau de LCP merci pour la confusion
les affranchis c'était limpide à demain
Stéphanie Despierre très belle soirée
sur LCP documentaire bien sûr qui
commence avec Jean-Pierre Gratien très
belle soirée
[Musique]